anyway here with reaction from the Trump
organization is Eric Trump you know I I
Eric I got to be honest I mean between
valuing and I know it's not funny to you
and it shouldn't be funny to you and it
shouldn't be funny to your family
because this has been you know the last
six or seven years of your life I but
you know I beseech you to control uh him
if you can he's he's saying to lawyer
Chris kis uh I will excuse him and draw
every negative inference that I can and
then and I think my favorite Eric is I'm
not here as the judge to listen to what
the witness has to say well what is he
there
for yeah Sean I take this very very
personally we've got an incredible
company we've never missed a payment
we've never missed a loan payment we pay
on time every single time we've never
had a default notice we've never
breached a covenant in a loan our
lenders love us every time we've gone in
we've taken a property we put hundreds
of millions of dollars of Our Own money
into it we've made them absolutely
incredible we've made Banks hundreds and
hundreds of millions of dollars they're
all our friends they've all testified
for us saying that Trump's always done a
great job we're a platinum lender we've
never had a problem they've never called
us into fault they've never had an issue
with our company but make no mistake
this isn't this isn't about the law
right this is about politics Sean you've
called it with your show she came as
soon as my father went down the
escalator she came out that very day and
she started going after him I'm getting
get him I'm going to take him down I'm
going to take down his family I'm going
to go into the Attorney General's office
every single day Sue Donald Trump and
then go home and I can't believe this is
being allowed to happen in in New York
there is no crime there is no victim our
banks made hundreds of millions of
dollars off of us our banks love us
they've never called a default on us it
doesn't it doesn't make any sense
there's bad people out there every day
that mess around in business that cause
harm no one has been harmed the exact
opposite in fact our banks as I keep on
saying have made a ton of money and love
us it it doesn't make any sense Sean
there's not one lender complaining
there's not one insurance company
complaining there is language correct me
if I'm wrong in in every single
valuation when you have a loan
application or an application for
insurance you put in language do not use
our valuations which by the way no they
have their own fiduciary responsibility
they've got to back up those numbers
they're not going to lend the kind of
money that that an organization like the
Trump organization is is borrowing to
somebody that doesn't do their own due
diligence that would be impossible
that's Insanity that doesn't happen in
the real
world the banks are the most regulated
industry in the entire world they have
to I mean they have a fiduciary duty as
you said they' get Suited by every
shareholder if they didn't and that's
like Sean Hannity going out to a bank
he's getting a mortgage on his home he
goes to the bank and says you know bank
I I think my house is worth a million
dollars I want you to take my word for
it and I want a million dollar mortgage
of course you're not going to do that
you know what they're going to do
they're going to send appraisers out
they're going to appraise the land
they're going to take a loan to value
ratio to make sure that they have
adequate coverage you're going to put in
equity the same thing happens to a much
greater degree in a commercial
transaction we would get mortgages on
property and we put hundreds of millions
of dollars into the properties only
further furthering the banks collateral
this whole narrative there is is asinine
again our banks loved us there are no
victims there was no crime of any sort
but Leticia James has to go after my
father and now you see the nrcc and all
all these different you know coalitions
you see all the attorney generals
fundraising on the fact that they're
going after Donald Trump and they're
they're going after his platform and
they're keeping him off the campaign
Trail so he can't be in South Carolina
and Iowa and New Hampshire and all the
places he wants to be they're all
fundraising on this charade and again
it's what Leticia James promised she was
going to do she promised this in her own
words I posted 100 of the videos today I
have played wanted to get Donald Trump
for the last six years so the only
comfort and and this is a state of the
United States of America right now Sean
it it certainly is in New York but they
want to cancel your ability to ever do
business in New York again uh they want
uh some conservator to take over your
properties they want to find you $250
million I guess if there's any comfort I
I have a very hard time believing that
this would stand on appeal if you get a
fair judge if you're able to get a fair
judge in New York you know if it wasn't
so ridiculous you know you would laugh
at it but this is your life this is your
family this has gone on now for all
these years and a judge saying he
doesn't want to hear from a witness is
this is this our country cuz that
doesn't sound like us thousands of
employees
Sean let's not forget about the
thousands of employees these are Maids
these are housekeepers these are
Engineers these are these are drivers
these are Bellman I mean people who
literally rely on our family and our
properties to put food on their PL you
know on their tables every single night
there's thousands of people who are
collateral damaged to Leticia james'
games and she doesn't give a damn I mean
she doesn't even consider these people I
mean isn't she responsible to take care
of New Yorkers and represent the best
interest of New Yorker these people have
incredible jobs because of us because of
the Trump organization because of our
family and she wants to put those people
in Peril Sean these people are cruel
they are cruel cruel people and they
will do anything for their own political
power and my father will keep fighting
it I'll keep fighting it and um in the
end we will win because whatever is
happening is just it's Unthinkable and
it makes no sense you get one Fair judge
and this thing's going to be thrown out
on his ear this this judge it's almost
like a Saturday night life skit he's so
bad it's it's worse than a Saturday
night life skit because you have to live
it Eric Trump thank you for being with
us hey Sean Hannity here hey click here
to subscribe to Fox News YouTube page
and catch our hottest interviews and
most compelling analysis you will not
get it anywhere
else